Nos dicen que: "Taylor abrió un restaurante. El
valor neto del restaurante (en miles de dólares),
t meses después de su apertura, se modela con
v(t) = 2t² - 20t. Taylor quiere saber cuál será
el valor neto más bajo del restaurante", subrayaré
eso, "y cuándo alcanzará ese valor". Así que vamos
a desglosarlo paso a paso. La función que describe
cómo el valor del restaurante -el valor neto del
restaurante- cambia en el tiempo está justo aquí.
Si tuviéramos que graficarla podríamos ver que el
coeficiente en el término cuadrático es positivo,
tendría una forma de parábola con apertura hacia
arriba. No sé exactamente cómo se ve, podemos
pensar en eso en un segundo. Va a tener algún
punto, justo aquí, que realmente es el vértice
de esta parábola donde va a alcanzar su valor
más bajo, y eso sucederá en algún momento t,
si te imaginas que esto de aquí es el eje t.
Así que mi primera pregunta es: ¿hay alguna forma
de reescribir esta función algebraicamente, de
modo que sea muy fácil identificar ese punto bajo
que es esencialmente el vértice de esta parábola?
Pausa este video y piénsalo. Muy bien, puedes
imaginar que la forma a la que me refiero es la
forma de vértice de la parábola, donde podemos ver
claramente el vértice, y la forma en que podemos
hacer eso en realidad es completando el cuadrado.
Así que lo primero que haremos es factorizar 2,
porque 2 es un factor común de ambos términos,
de modo que v(t) = 2 (t² - 10t), y voy a dejar
un espacio porque completar el cuadrado que nos
lleva a la forma de vértice se trata de sumar y
restar el mismo valor en un lado. En realidad
no estamos cambiando el valor de ese lado,
pero lo estamos escribiendo de manera que
tengamos una expresión cuadrada perfecta,
y luego probablemente vamos a sumar o restar algún
valor aquí. Ahora, ¿cómo hacemos para que esta
expresión sea un cuadrado perfecto? Si alguno
de estos pasos sobre completar el cuadrado no
te resulta familiar, te invito a que revises en
Khan Academy cómo completar el cuadrado. Pero la
forma en que completamos el cuadrado es mirar este
coeficiente de primer grado que es -10, tomamos
la mitad y lo elevamos al cuadrado, entonces la
mitad de -10 es -5, y si lo elevamos al cuadrado
es igual a 25, así que sumamos 25. Entonces
esto convertirá la expresión en un cuadrado
perfecto, y podemos ver que esto es equivalente:
si sumamos 25, todo esto es equivalente a t -5²,
sólo esta parte de aquí. Es por eso que tomamos
la mitad de esto y lo elevamos al cuadrado. Pero,
como lo mencionamos hace unos minutos, no podemos
simplemente agregar 25 a un lado de una ecuación
como esta, eso hace que esta igualdad ya no
sea cierta. De hecho, no sólo agregamos 25,
recordemos que tenemos este 2 aquí, agregamos 2
por 25. Podemos verificar que si redistribuimos
el 2, obtendremos 2 (t² - 20 + 50) + 2 x 25, de
modo que para que la igualdad siga siendo cierta,
tenemos que restar 50. Para ser claros,
no es que estemos haciendo algo extraño,
todo lo que hicimos fue sumar 50 y restar
50, podemos decir que agregamos 25 no 50,
pero cuando agregamos 25 aquí toda la expresión
que está entre paréntesis se multiplica por 2, así
que realmente agregamos 50. Entonces restamos 50
aquí para llegar a lo que originalmente teníamos,
y cuando lo vemos de esa manera ahora v(t) será
igual a 2 por esto que tenemos aquí, ya que vimos
que es (t - 5²) y luego tenemos - 50. Ahora, ¿por
qué es útil esta forma? Esta es una forma de
vértice, es muy fácil identificar el vértice, es
muy fácil distinguir cuál es el punto más bajo:
el punto bajo se alcanza cuando esta parte
se minimiza; si tienes algo al cuadrado va
a llegar a su punto más bajo cuando este algo
sea 0, de lo contrario será un valor positivo,
y entonces esta parte de aquí va a ser igual a 0
cuando t sea igual a 5, de modo que el valor más
bajo resulta cuando t es igual a 5. Así que si
decimos v(5) = 2 (5 - 5)² - 50, observemos que
todo esto se convierte en 0, entonces v(5) = -50,
es entonces cuando llegamos a nuestro punto más
bajo en términos del valor neto del restaurante. t
representa meses, reescribimos nuestra función en
forma de vértice, de modo que es fácil identificar
este valor, y vemos que este punto bajo resulta
cuando t = 5, es decir, en un tiempo de 5 meses. Y
entonces, ¿cuál es ese valor neto más bajo? Bueno,
es -50, y recordemos la función nos da el
valor neto en miles de dólares, por lo que
el valor neto más bajo del restaurante es igual
a -50,000 dólares. Y podríamos preguntarnos ¿cómo
podemos tener un valor negativo de algo? Bueno,
imaginemos que el edificio vale 50,000 dólares,
pero el restaurante debe 100,000 dólares, entonces
tendría un valor neto de menos 50,000 dólares.